Le château de Chantilly est le symbole
de l'excellence française
en matière d'architecture.
Situé à 50 km au nord de Paris,
l'édifice trône depuis un millénaire au sommet
des plus belles constructions de France.
- Chantilly, c'est exceptionnel.
C'est le plus extraordinaire
des patrimoines français.
- On a tout ce que l'architecture
et l'art des jardins a fait de plus beau,
en France au cours des siècles.
Un château monumental d'une superficie
totale de 10 000 mètres carrés.
Autant que le palais de l'Élysée.
Un parc tout aussi gigantesque.
- Le grand parterre de Chantilly,
en superficie,
c'est 6 terrains de football.
- 12 km de perspective.
C'est la plus grande perspective
de France encore aujourd'hui.
Les écuries princières
les plus grandes d'Europe.
- C'est la même longueur
que la façade des Invalides.
Cette démesure fera même de Chantilly
le rival du plus beau château du monde.
- C'est un petit Versailles.
Nous allons vous raconter le chantier
de cette demeure monumentale,
où chaque étape de construction
fut un combat.
- Ça a été un effort énorme pour
les équipes qui ont dû travailler ici.
- À l'heure actuelle, on déconseille
fortement, voire on interdit
la construction sur ces zones.
- À Chantilly, on ne peut pas
construire comme ailleurs.
À Chantilly, il faut innover.
Des fondations sur pilotis.
Aux symétries des jardins à la française.
En passant par la création
d'un dôme colossal.
Comment les bâtisseurs ont-ils pu
défier l'impossible ?
Quelle prouesse technique
réalisée au XVIIᵉ siècle,
par le plus grand paysagiste de France,
André Le Nôtre,
permettra à Chantilly
de dépasser Versailles ?
À Chantilly, il y avait des fontaines
qui marchaient en continu.
- Je ne sais pas si vous imaginez l'effet
que ça a pu faire à Louis XIV.
Grâce à des animations 3D inédites
et aux témoignages
des plus grands spécialistes,
nous remonterons 10 siècles
de travaux titanesques.
Du château fort médiéval à la demeure
princière d'aujourd'hui.
Voici l'histoire de l'une des constructions
les plus époustouflantes de France
miraculée de l'histoire,
le château de Chantilly.
Chantilly est un château
qui cache bien son jeu.
Connu aujourd'hui pour ses mythiques
courses de chevaux.
Ces 815 peintures qui en font la 2ᵉ plus grande
collection de tableaux anciens après le Louvre.
Chaque année, c'est plus d'un demi-million
de visiteurs qui vient déambuler,
à travers un domaine de 7000 hectares,
soit autant que Paris intra-muros.
Et pourtant, beaucoup l'ignorent,
mais Chantilly n'a pas toujours été
aussi raffinée et ordonnée qu'aujourd'hui,
bien au contraire.
- L'histoire de Chantilly
est une histoire faite de destruction
et de reconstruction incessante.
- Chantilly, c'est cinq châteaux en un.
Pour décrypter les nombreuses vies
de cette construction,
il nous faut remonter le temps
de plus d'un millénaire.
Nous sommes au XIᵉ siècle,
en plein Moyen Âge.
À l'époque, le Royaume de France
n'est pas encore unifié.
Sa capitale royale, Senlis,
située à 45 km au nord de Paris,
est la cible de nombreuses attaques.
- L'époque n'est pas très sûre
et donc il faut des points défensifs.
- Tout autour de cette cité, à plusieurs
lieues de distance, plusieurs km.
On va trouver comme ça des forteresses
qui sont censées protéger Senlis,
sur la route qui mène
de Paris à la Picardie.
Mais un emplacement pose problème pour
la construction d'une forteresse.
Celui de la forêt de Chantilly,
à sept kilomètres de Senlis.
- Ce sont des marécages, ni plus ni moins.
De la tourbe, des arbres sauvages.
- C'est un territoire agricole
sur un plateau traversé par une vallée,
la vallée de la rivière Nonette
qui est une vallée marécageuse.
Cette rivière, appelée la Nonette,
est un cours d'eau
de plusieurs mètres de large,
mais au débit très faible,
seulement 1,8 mètres cubes par seconde.
Alors qu'elle sera un atout incroyable
quelques siècles plus tard,
notamment pour concurrencer
le château de Versailles.
Au Moyen Âge, elle est extrêmement
contraignante pour les bâtisseurs.
- C'est extrêmement boueux.
Il faut aller jusqu'à dix mètres de
profondeur avant de trouver un rocher
sur lequel on peut se fonder.
À l'époque, creuser sur dix mètres,
c'était un défi qui n'était
absolument pas possible.
- Même à l'heure actuelle, on déconseille
fortement, voire on interdit,
la construction sur ces zones.
Mais une découverte va tout changer.
- Heureusement, au milieu de cette vallée
marécageuse, il y a un éperon rocheux,
une masse rocheuse qui va permettre de
construire un château à l'époque médiévale.
Cet énorme rocher calcaire
à la géométrie irrégulière,
sera donc la base du futur château-fort.
Mais avant de débuter la construction,
de nombreux défis attendent les bâtisseurs.
- Ça va demander du travail
d'arasement aux bâtisseurs.
- Il faut essayer d'aplanir
le rocher pour qu'il puisse
être l'assise solide
sur laquelle vont se dresser
les parois, les courtines.
Seulement muni d'une pioche,
les constructeurs creusent
autour et sur le rocher
pour dégager un socle épuré.
- Ils ont dû creuser dans le rocher
extrêmement dur,
pour encercler le château d'eau
pour faire en sorte
que le château soit complètement
entouré de douves.
- C'est assez complexe comme opération.
C'est un travail très pénible.
Cette entaille permet de récupérer
plus de 7000 mètres cubes de pierre,
soit de quoi remplir
plus de 200 conteneurs.
Un stock colossal, bien utile
pour construire les premières maçonneries.
- Comme rien ne se perd au Moyen Âge,
quand on taille le rocher,
on en profite pour avoir
une petite pierre qui va servir
aussi à l'intérieur des maçonneries.
Et de la pierre, il en faut à Chantilly.
Car à l'époque, les bâtisseurs ont l'habitude
de doubler l'épaisseur des murs.
- À l'époque, ils construisaient
pour que ça dure.
Ils ne faisaient pas à l'économie
pour 2 raisons.
Premièrement, le château devait être
solide au début, au Moyen âge,
pour résister éventuellement
à des attaques.
Et il faut le dire, en quelque sorte,
c'était aussi par ignorance.
Ils ne savaient pas jusqu'où ils pouvaient
réduire l'épaisseur des murs
ou des matériaux pour que ça tienne.
Donc, ils doublaient, triplaient
pour être sûr que ça tienne.
Et le résultat est qu'ils ont
construit des choses
qui sont beaucoup trop solides.
Ici, les murs des soubassements ne font pas
moins de trois mètres d'épaisseur.
De quoi permettre la construction
d'un véritable château fort défensif.
Chantilly est née.
- Il y avait sept tours à Chantilly
qui montaient très haut
et vous aviez des courtines,
des murs entre ces tours,
qui montaient aussi haut que ces tours
et cela permettait
d'accueillir l'artillerie.
Preuve de la qualité extraordinaire
des constructeurs de l'époque,
les soubassements médiévaux servent encore
de fondation à l'actuel château.
C'est ce que nous révèle
Pierre-Antoine Gatier,
architecte en chef
des Monuments historiques.
- La chance que nous avons
avec la lumière rasante,
on voit toutes les traces d'outils
des marques de tâcherons.
Quasiment chaque pierre
est identifiable par ces marques,
qui sont la mémoire
de l'organisation du chantier,
la mémoire de ces tailleurs de pierre
très habiles.
Chaque tailleur de pierre avait sa marque
et marquer les pierres avec un petit signe
qui montrait que c'était lui
qui l'avait coupé.
Comme ça les ouvriers étaient payés
au fur et à mesure
du travail qu'ils avaient fourni.
Les vestiges médiévaux les plus visibles,
ce sont d'une part les douves
et d'autre part la base des tours
du château-fort.
Sur ces 2 bases de tours, on voit qu'il y a
encore des archères qui sont en place,
c'est-à-dire des fentes
verticales allongées,
qui permettaient depuis l'intérieur
de la tour de tirer,
pour se défendre contre
les assauts des ennemis.
Et ce n'est pas tout.
Le public d'aujourd'hui l'ignore,
mais l'héritage médiéval le plus
marquant à Chantilly est ailleurs.
Il faut prendre de la hauteur
pour le voir.
C'est le plan du château.
Une sorte de triangle équilatéral
de 70 mètres de côté,
qui est depuis un millénaire la matrice
architecturale de Chantilly.
- Quelle que soit l'époque de construction,
tous les bâtisseurs,
devront immanquablement repartir
de ce premier plan,
plus ou moins triangulaire que vont élaborer
les premiers bâtisseurs
à l'époque médiévale
sur cet éperon rocheux.
Un plan qui va poser des problèmes
au XVIᵉ siècle,
quand le nouveau propriétaire de Chantilly
voudra transformer le château-fort,
en demeure princière flamboyante.
150 ans après le Moyen Âge, en 1560,
une nouvelle campagne de grands travaux
est sur le point d'être lancée à Chantilly,
à la demande du nouveau maître des lieux,
un certain Anne de Montmorency.
- Anne, ici, est un prénom masculin.
C'est un peu déroutant pour nous,
mais c'est bien un homme.
Et cet homme n'est pas n'importe qui.
C'est l'une des personnes les plus
puissantes de France au XVIᵉ siècle.
Il est connétable, autrement dit
le chef suprême des armées,
Et il est immensément riche.
Anne de Montmorency était quand même
propriétaire de 600 fiefs
et de 130 châteaux et seigneuries,
plus des hôtels particuliers à Paris.
Et on sait qu'il était
très féru d'architecture.
- Ce personnage essentiel qui va avoir
des possessions dans toute la France,
va faire de Chantilly
sa principale résidence.
Et ça va être un tournant pour
l'histoire de Chantilly, vraiment,
avec des chantiers immenses
qui vont être menés.
Des chantiers qui vont très vite devenir
un casse-tête pour les ouvriers.
Car après avoir ajouté des fenêtres
à la forteresse médiévale,
le commanditaire veut l'agrandir pour recevoir
les plus grands rois de France et d'Europe.
- Il faut s'imaginer que la Cour de France
qui se déploie,
c'est plusieurs milliers
de personnes qui bougent.
- On trouve que le château
est un peu petit, on veut l'agrandir,
on est assez contraint par les sept tours
et la forme triangulaire.
- On va avoir, sans arrêt, à Chantilly
le besoin de trouver de l'espace.
Et ce n'est pas le seul problème
que pose la forteresse médiévale.
Le connétable veut que son château respecte
les codes architecturaux de la Renaissance.
À l'époque, les nouvelles constructions arborent
une architecture parfaitement symétrique,
comme ici à Chambord.
Tout le contraire de Chantilly.
- Donc c'est vraiment une disposition,
qui a, selon les mots des hommes
de la Renaissance, une sauvage quadrature.
Il n'y a pas d'angle droit,
c'est complètement bizarre.
- Sur ce rocher, il était très compliqué
de faire quoi que ce soit de symétrique.
Pour satisfaire les exigences
du commanditaire,
les ouvriers vont réaliser
un véritable tour de force.
Il décide de construire
une extension sur l'eau.
Un petit château en avant
de la forteresse,
qui servira de hall d'entrée majestueux
pour les invités.
Et pour réaliser cet incroyable défi
de construire sur l'eau,
ils vont s'inspirer de la plus grande
ville flottante au monde.
- Ils ont construit le petit château
de la même façon,
que la ville de Venise.
Ils ont enfoncé des piliers en bois
dans la boue, sous l'eau.
- On va mettre en place ce qu'on appelle
des sonnettes ou des moutons,
qui sont des sortes de grands poids.
On va faire descendre régulièrement
sur le pieux et tant qu'il descend,
on continue à l'enfoncer.
Une méthode qui nécessite plusieurs
précautions techniques,
sous peine de voir
la structure s'écrouler.
- Il faut que les pilotis soient
toujours sous l'eau.
La règle d'or, c'est celle-là.
Parce que s'ils sont en dehors de l'eau,
il y a une zone de contact
et de pourrissement qui peut se faire.
Il faut qu'ils soient toujours noyés
dans l'eau et par-dessus, on fait un radier,
des poutres croisées
et on met des maçonneries,
qui vont servir de support
à la construction elle-même.
Grâce à ce système de pilotis,
des dizaines de mètres vont pouvoir
être gagnés sur l'eau.
Mais très vite, un nouveau problème
se pose pour les bâtisseurs.
Le petit château, qui doit être
le nouveau joyau de Chantilly,
impose un changement radical
dans le choix des matières premières.
- Là, l'objectif, c'est que ce soit beau
de l'extérieur, élégant, esthétique.
Ce n'est pas l'objectif
du château médiéval.
Pas question donc d'utiliser la pierre
du rocher comme à l'époque médiévale.
Il faut trouver un nouveau gisement.
Mais où ?
Nous sommes à Saint-Maximin, dans l'Oise,
à six mètres sous terre.
Ici se trouvent des galeries gigantesques
que connaît par cœur Denis Montagne.
Son métier :
inspecteur de carrières souterraines.
- Vous voyez le décollement là.
Il y a une fracturation naturelle.
La grande, là.
C'est la pierre tombale assurée,
si vous passez en dessous le mauvais jour.
Aujourd'hui sous surveillance,
ces carrières sont une chance incroyable
pour les ouvriers de Chantilly,
à la Renaissance.
Elles sont situées seulement
à sept kilomètres du chantier.
- Dans l'ensemble, depuis 2000 ans,
vous avez une activité extractive.
On a la chance d'avoir un des plus
grands sites carriers de France
avec une pierre de qualité et qui a
fourni partout pour toutes les époques.
- Donc il a servi toute
la construction de Paris,
la construction de Versailles,
tous les grands châteaux.
Si ces carrières sont si prisées,
c'est qu'elle abrite une pierre
d'une qualité exceptionnelle.
- C'est une pierre homogène,
de qualité mécanique, qui est belle,
qui est réputée, donc elle se taille bien.
Vous la rayez à l'ongle.
Elle se travaille bien à l'outil.
Elle a tout pour plaire.
- Une pierre assez blonde qui joue bien
avec le soleil de Picardie.
Et puis c'est une pierre qui permet
des sculptures de très bonne qualité.
Mais avant de sculpter la pierre,
il faut l'extraire.
À la Renaissance,
les ouvriers de Chantilly
n'avaient qu'un seul outil
à leur disposition,
une sorte de piolet très rudimentaire.
- Vous allez enlever de la pierre
de manière régulière,
sur toute la surface
que vous voulez extraire.
Les tailleurs de pierre répètent alors
l'opération de chaque côté du bloc.
- Et à ce moment-là,
le bloc va se détacher.
C'est un travail éreintant.
- Vous avez un rendement,
pour quelqu'un qui travaille
une dizaine d'heures par jour,
d'un mètre cube par semaine.
Sachant que le bâtiment à construire
fait 60 mètres par 30 mètres,
le chantier du petit château
prend beaucoup de temps.
Trop au goût du commanditaire.
- Ils sont toujours sous la pression
de finir les travaux au bon moment,
parce que le connétable
et la cour vont venir.
Et parfois, ils sont obligés
de travailler très vite
et peut-être trop vite pour pouvoir
avancer dans les temps.
Et on voit qu'une partie
de la fondation du petit Château
n'est pas très bien faite,
avec des matériaux de récupération,
qu'on a mis très vite en œuvre.
Il est probable que c'est
une contrainte pas du tout technique,
mais qui est liée
à un commanditaire exigeant
qui trouve que le chantier
n'avance pas assez vite.
Ce qui aura pour conséquence
un affaissement du plancher de 8 cm,
5 siècles plus tard.
Toujours est-il qu'à l'époque,
tout semble tenir.
Le nouveau bâtiment est terminé
en seulement 6 ans
et respecte parfaitement
les exigences du commanditaire.
Une structure rectangulaire
à la géométrie parfaite.
Une superficie supplémentaire
de 2000 mètres carrés.
Le tout orné de centaines de sculptures.
- C'est l'élégance, la maîtrise,
la rigueur.
Une répartition quand même
très mesurée de l'ornement,
une vraie leçon de maîtrise
de la géométrie.
Chantilly est prêt à recevoir et à éblouir
les plus grands rois d'Europe.
Cela sera le cas avec l'empereur
Charles Quint,
le monarque le plus puissant à l'époque.
- Charles Quint vient à Chantilly,
il est tout à fait ébloui.
Il est tellement ébloui
qu'il demande à Montmorency,
de lui céder Chantilly
contre une province des Pays-Bas.
- Chantilly fait partie, à la Renaissance,
des grands châteaux
qui vont servir de modèle d'architecture
pour toutes les autres constructions.
Mais ce leadership va être remis en cause
moins d'un siècle plus tard.
Un nouveau concurrent arrive
et va pousser le château de Chantilly,
à des transformations radicales.
Nous sommes dans les années 1660,
sous le règne de Louis XIV.
Une nouvelle construction est au centre
de toutes les attentions.
Il s'agit du château de Versailles.
- C'est un chantier hors normes,
des sommes considérables,
qui ont été dépensées.
- Versailles, c'est 1400 fontaines.
Enfin, c'est délirant.
- Il faut bien dire que personne
ne peut rivaliser avec Versailles
et ça, c'est très clair
pour tout le monde.
Pour tout le monde, sauf un,
le nouveau propriétaire
du château de Chantilly.
Il s'appelle le Grand Condé.
C'est le cousin du roi
et son plus grand rival.
- Il avait dépensé une grande partie
de sa fortune en combattant le roi,
parce qu'il voulait devenir calife
à la place du calife, ça n'a pas marché.
À la fin, il a été puni
et enfermé dans son château.
- Et donc, que va-t-il faire ?
Il va se lancer dans une nouvelle bataille.
Cette bataille contre le Roi-Soleil,
le prince déchu ne va pas la mener
sur l'architecture du château,
mais sur un autre aspect du domaine.
- Il s'est concentré sur l'autre sujet
à la mode à cette époque,
c'était justement les jardins.
Le jardin à la française est inventé.
Tous les nobles de France veulent
créer des jardins à la française
qui sont très à la mode,
comme tout simplement,
symbole de leur puissance, de la richesse.
Et le Grand Condé veut montrer
qu'il est presque,
voire aussi puissant
que le roi à Versailles.
Le projet est extrêmement ambitieux.
Chantilly étant toujours entourée
d'une gigantesque zone marécageuse.
À l'époque, une seule personne semble
en mesure de relever pareil défi.
Son nom : André le Nôtre.
Un architecte et un paysagiste de génie.
- C'est déjà un jardinier bien installé.
Il a une quarantaine d'années,
sa réputation est faite avec Fontainebleau,
les Tuileries et Vaux le Vicomte.
- C'est quelqu'un qui est d'âge mûr,
qui a des connaissances,
à la fois architecturales,
de mathématiques.
Enfin, c'est le premier grand
paysagiste de l'histoire.
Mais problème, quand le Grand Condé
le contact,
André le Nôtre est déjà pris
sur un autre projet d'envergure.
- Louis XIV le choisit pour aménager
les jardins de Versailles.
- Je pense que pour le Nôtre,
quitter Versailles,
c'était une chose qui n'était pas évidente,
il était attaché au domaine Royal
et tous les autres domaines
étaient de domaine secondaire.
Chantilly n'est pas un domaine
comme les autres.
Ici se trouve un élément rare et longtemps
considéré comme une faiblesse :
Une rivière.
- Qu'a-t-on à Chantilly en grandes
richesses ? C'est l'eau.
Il y a beaucoup d'eau. C'est fantastique.
À Versailles, il n'y en a pas.
- Mais encore faut-il savoir la maîtriser.
André Le Nôtre donne son accord.
Il accepte de mener de front
les deux chantiers.
Il ne le sait pas encore,
mais il va réussir à Chantilly,
des prouesses techniques qui vont dépasser
celles du château de Versailles.
En 1662, les travaux sont lancés.
Premier objectif :
assainir la zone marécageuse.
- Pour arriver à assécher ce genre
de terrain, il faut drainer.
Il faut essayer de faire arriver
toutes les eaux de part et d'autre
sur un canal central.
La zone à drainer est considérable.
Presque 7000 hectares.
Autant que Paris intra-muros.
Le Nôtre imagine alors un canal
aux dimensions gigantesques,
60 mètres de large
sur 2500 mètres de long.
Autant qu'une piste d'atterrissage
d'avion de ligne.
Le but ? Assécher les marécages.
- Les travaux de terrassement et de percement
des canaux vont être colossaux,
dans les documents d'archives,
on trouve régulièrement mention d'équipes,
de 200 ouvriers qui doivent
creuser, percer, évacuer la terre,
pour donner naissance à ces canaux.
150 000 mètres cubes de terre
sont décaissés.
De quoi remplir
plus de 5700 semi-remorques.
- Le Grand Canal,
ça a été un effort énorme,
pour les équipes
qui ont dû travailler ici.
Les ouvriers vont rencontrer
un autre problème.
En creusant dans le sol,
la nappe phréatique qui est
peu profonde à Chantilly, remonte,
ce qui rend le drainage impossible.
André Le Nôtre va devoir étanchéifier
le fond de son grand canal.
- Il avait une connaissance hydraulique
très pointue du site
et il a pu créer des canaux
qu'il a recouvert d'argile,
afin d'isoler effectivement
le fond de son canal
et d'éviter que les eaux de la nappe
remontent et remplissent ces canaux.
À ce moment-là, le fond de son canal
étant bien isolé,
sur les berges de son canal, on pouvait
drainer les eaux des zones humides.
Après deux ans d'un chantier colossal,
le drainage est lancé.
Les terres s'assèchent,
la rivière est maîtrisée.
À la vue de ce grand canal,
le rival du roi jubile.
- Pour vous donner une idée,
le canal de Versailles fait 1 km,
celui de Chantilly, en fait 2,5 km.
Mais il reste encore énormément
de travail pour concurrencer Versailles.
Le chantier entre alors
dans sa deuxième phase,
celle du découpage très symétrique
du paysage.
Les routes sont élargies.
Un axe gigantesque
est créé du nord au sud.
- Douze kilomètres de perspective.
C'est la plus grande perspective
de France encore aujourd'hui.
De part et d'autre de la perspective,
se dessinent des formes géométriques,
au milieu de parterres
aux dimensions impressionnantes.
- Il faut savoir que le grand parterre
de Chantilly en superficie,
c'est 6 terrains de football,
donc ce n'est pas neutre quand même.
Mais comment réaliser des symétries parfaite
sur de telles distances ?
À l'époque, les ouvriers ne disposent
que d'une corde à nœuds
et de perches pour définir les tracés.
C'est sans compter sur l'incroyable
talent d'André Le Nôtre.
- Il a adapté la symétrie
à l'œil humain pour que,
même si ce n'était pas
exactement symétrique,
on a l'impression que c'était le cas.
- C'est vraiment un génie pour ça.
il sait calculer la longueur
qu'il faut donner à un bassin,
pour que même s'il est rectangulaire
est l'air d'un carré.
Un savoir-faire prodigieux
qui transforme peu à peu,
les terres marécageuses de Chantilly
en parterres parfaitement ordonnés.
Le rêve du Grand Condé prend forme.
Mais le chantier va connaître
plusieurs coups d'arrêt,
qui vont mettre en péril le projet.
- Le problème du Grand Condé,
c'est qu'il arrive difficilement à avoir,
son architecte paysagiste parce qu'il
est toujours retenu par le roi à Versailles.
- C'est une vie moderne d'une star,
c'est-à-dire qu'il vient un jour,
deux jours à Chantilly.
- Quand il vient, alors là,
c'est l'agitation.
Tout le monde doit être à son écoute,
on doit recueillir ses avis,
lui faire dessiner des esquisses,
organiser les travaux
jusqu'à sa prochaine venue.
- On a d'innombrables lettres où on dit
il faut faire venir Monsieur Le Nôtre,
il faut qu'il soit là et il a une bonne raison de
ne pas être à Chantilly car il est à Versailles.
- On a là aussi une rivalité
qui aura André Le Nôtre sur place.
Le prince de Chantilly ira même
jusqu'à affréter un véhicule,
spécialement pour l'architecte
pour qu'il puisse revenir
travailler au château.
Car il lui reste encore
un dernier élément à créer,
et non des moindres.
La création de jeux d'eau
capable de couler en continu,
ce qui représente à l'époque
une prouesse technique exceptionnelle.
- Maîtriser l'hydraulique qui garde
encore un côté un peu magique,
pour les hommes du commun à l'époque.
Ça, c'est la vraie preuve du pouvoir.
Et donc, plus un jardin
aura de jeux d'eau,
plus la preuve du pouvoir du propriétaire
du domaine sera apportée.
André Le Nôtre mesure l'ampleur
de la tâche qui l'attend,
lui qui a toutes les peines du monde à faire
fonctionner les fontaines de Versailles.
- Versailles, on a souligné que ça puait
parfois, quand ça marche 20 minutes,
c'est bien et ça fuit tant que ça peut.
On a même imaginé à Versailles
une manière de montrer les jardins.
- Ils faisaient couler les fontaines
seulement quand le roi se baladait
et encore en fonction
de là où il se trouvait.
Quand il se baladait
dans les différentes zones,
il y avait des petits ouvriers
qui ouvraient les fontaines
quand il arrivait et qui les fermaient
tout de suite derrière.
Comment André Le Nôtre va réussir à Chantilly
ce qu'il n'a pas réussi à faire à Versailles ?
C'est seulement 300 ans plus tard
que le mystère sera levé.
Quand en 1994, un ancien ingénieur
découvre un bâtiment à l'abandon.
à proximité du parc de Chantilly.
- J'apercevais ce bâtiment dans lequel
il n'y avait aucun mouvement.
Et lorsque je m'adressais aux habitants :
Qu'est-ce que c'est ce bâtiment ?
Les gens disaient : C'est la machine.
Mais quelle machine ?
Personne n'était capable de me répondre.
Yves Buck, aidé par des amis,
se lance à la recherche
de cette mystérieuse machine
et finit par en trouver des représentations
dans un ouvrage du XVIIIᵉ siècle.
- On a commencé à fantasmer,
on a fait des plans,
on a fait des maquettes...
Après 18 mois de travail
et l'assemblage de 250 pièces,
l'énigme est enfin résolue.
Il s'agit d'une immense pompe à eau unique
en France, créée par André Le Nôtre.
Au XVIIᵉ siècle, le seul moyen de créer
des jeux d'eau est d'utiliser la gravité.
André Le Nôtre a donc conçu cette machine
pour amener l'eau du canal en hauteur.
- L'énergie provient
de l'eau de la Nonette,
ça permet d'entraîner cette roue
qui a pour but d'entraîner bien sûr,
les pompes aspirantes et refoulantes
par le biais des engrenages...
- Cette eau va être renvoyée
grâce à des canalisations,
sous le toit du dôme de ce pavillon.
Puis cette eau par une autre canalisation
va regagner un réservoir
absolument gigantesque qui se trouve
sur le plateau de Chantilly,
en hauteur, au-dessus
de la vallée marécageuse.
Ce réservoir, situé à dix mètres
au-dessus du parc de Chantilly,
pouvait contenir à l'époque
33 millions de litres,
soit l'équivalent
de 13 piscines olympiques.
Et une fois que l'eau est
dans les réservoirs, par gravité,
on alimente les cascades du domaine.
Prévu pour l'alimentation des jets d'eau
située à l'ouest du château,
ce système hydraulique s'avère
particulièrement efficace.
Preuve en est avec les grandes
cascades aujourd'hui disparues.
Au XVIIᵉ siècle, elles sont considérées
comme le point d'orgue des jardins.
100 jets d'eau sur 15 mètres de dénivelé.
Alors, combien de temps fonctionne-t-elle
grâce à la machine de Chantilly ?
- Au XVIIᵉ siècle, la machine de Chantilly
est la plus performante de France.
Non pas en capacité ou en débit,
mais qu'elle tournait régulièrement.
- Et avec le volume du réservoir,
elle pouvait couler
2 jours sans s'arrêter.
Sans être obligé de remettre en route
la machine à eau pour remplir le réservoir.
Vous imaginez deux jours
sans interruption ?
C'est du jamais vu en France
pour des jets d'eau aussi complexes.
Mais là où Chantilly va définitivement
surpasser Versailles,
c'est grâce à un tout autre système
créé par André le Nôtre.
Et il est d'une simplicité déconcertante.
Pour les fontaines situées
à l'est du château,
la machine est trop loin
pour les alimenter.
Il faut donc trouver un autre moyen
d'amener l'eau en hauteur.
C'est alors qu'est découvert un ancien
aqueduc caché dans les bois.
Quand André le Nôtre arrive à Chantilly, il
découvre cet aqueduc du prince dans les bois.
Il est émerveillé par cette arrivée
d'eau qui est en hauteur,
par rapport aux parterres à la française.
Neuf mètres de différence.
Une source surélevée
qui coule en continu.
André le Nôtre sent qu'il touche au but.
Il crée alors une dérivation
de cinq mètres,
pour alimenter un énorme bassin
de charge de 40 000 litres d'eau.
Donc depuis ce bassin de charge,
vous avez un ensemble de tuyaux,
qui partent dans tous les sens,
qui passent sous la terre
et qui vont vers les bassins.
- Pour créer une accélération des courants,
on réduit en fait le diamètre.
C'est un peu l'effet d'un jet d'eau,
quand on tourne la buse,
plus on réduit le diamètre,
plus l'eau va vite,
ça permet de créer du courant.
L'exploit est en marche.
- À Chantilly, il y avait des fontaines
qui marchaient en continu.
À l'époque, ça s'appelait
le miracle des eaux.
- C'était vraiment exceptionnel, vraiment.
Au total, c'est plus de 7 km
de tuyaux souterrains,
qui alimentent
tous les jeux d'eau à Chantilly.
Le pari est réussi.
La nature est domptée.
Ne reste plus qu'à montrer
cette prouesse au monde entier.
Le 23 avril 1671,
le prince invite à Chantilly
son cousin le Roi-Soleil,
pour trois jours de fête.
Alors, comment va réagir
celui qui condamne à mort,
quiconque lui fait de l'ombre ?
- Il y a 2000 personnes.
C'est vraiment l'un des principaux événements
à Chantilly du vivant du Grand Condé.
C'est l'époque où les jardins
sont en grande partie terminés.
- Il va accueillir son cousin,
lui montrer son domaine,
mais en lui indiquant,
que toute cette magnificence
est faite pour lui.
Fin stratagème,
le Grand Condé laisse le roi croire
qu'il a transformé Chantilly pour lui.
Le roi s'émerveille.
Le Grand Condé savoure.
Je ne sais pas si vous imaginez
l'effet que ça a pu faire à Louis XIV,
quand il a été invité
par le Grand Condé.
En pleine nuit, le soir
et le matin ça marchait.
L'effet devait être saisissant
pour lui quand même.
- Grâce à tous ces jets d'eau, avec
cette grande réussite d'André Le Nôtre,
en cela, Chantilly dépasse
Versailles définitivement.
- Le Grand Condé, probablement
en son for intérieur,
prend un peu comme
une vengeance face au roi.
Les années passent, les générations
se succèdent à Chantilly.
Mais la rivalité avec Versailles continue,
même après la mort du Roi-Soleil.
- Les travaux à Versailles
se sont arrêtés net, à ce moment-là.
Les ouvriers se trouvaient
un peu sans grand chose à faire.
Et donc le prince à Chantilly a dit :
"Moi aussi, j'ai un château. Venez chez moi."
Cette nouvelle main d'œuvre va changer
radicalement le visage de Chantilly.
À commencer par les façades
du Grand Château.
On a changé toutes les parties hautes,
il faut imaginer de grandes tours.
Et puis au sommet, on a placé
des lanternes, des toitures,
on a ouvert complètement les murs
par un très grand nombre de fenêtres.
Les modifications se poursuivent
à l'intérieur.
C'est le cas dans le petit château
devenu entre-temps,
le lieu de vie des princes de Chantilly.
- On va créer une grande galerie
comme la Galerie des Glaces.
Avec les mêmes dispositifs,
vous allez avoir des baies,
qui sont les baies de la Renaissance
qui vont être agrandies, réaménagées
et de l'autre côté, on va obstruer les baies
de la Renaissance pour y placer des miroirs,
de sorte que la lumière des baies
va pouvoir se refléter sur les miroirs
placés juste en face, comme dans
la galerie des glaces de Versailles.
- Donc c'est un petit Versailles.
Mais là où le savoir-faire de ces ouvriers
versaillais va être mis à rude épreuve,
c'est dans la construction à Chantilly
d'un nouveau bâtiment,
qui va battre tous les records.
Situé à 300 m du château.
Voici les écuries princières
les plus grandes d'Europe.
- Ces écuries sont plus grandes
que le château
et c'est quasiment unique dans
les châteaux français ou européens.
- C'est la même longueur
que la façade des Invalides.
- 186 mètres de long, 25 mètres de large.
C'est incroyable !
Absolument incroyable !
Divisée en deux nefs gigantesques,
capable d'accueillir 240 chevaux.
Ornée de sculptures
d'une finesse exceptionnelle.
Ce temple du cheval rivalise
avec les écuries royales.
- Mais c'est un chantier
tout à fait démesuré,
qui va engloutir des millions
et des millions.
Pourtant, ce chantier
qui va durer plus de 20 ans
et qui tournera au cauchemar
pour les ouvriers,
avait commencé par une bonne surprise.
- On se rend compte qu'en fait,
sous la pelouse de Chantilly
existe la pierre qu'on utilise encore
à l'époque, la pierre de Saint-Maximin.
- Des pierres à 100 mètres
de la porte des grandes écuries,
une source naturelle de pierres,
mais gigantesque.
Deux hectares et demi de pierre
à tailler dans le brut,
pour un bâtiment telles
Les grandes écuries.
Je veux dire, c'est formidable !
Aussi incroyable
que cela puisse paraître,
sous les grandes écuries se cache
un labyrinthe aussi grand,
que trois terrains de football.
À l'époque, ce n'est pas moins
de 50 000 blocs de pierre,
qui vont être extraits par
ces grands trous creusés dans la roche.
- Ces cheminées ont deux fonctions.
La 1ʳᵉ les flux d'air, et puis la 2ᵉ,
c'est aussi l'extraction des pierres
puisqu'on y mettait des pièces de bois,
les charpentes
et avec un système de poulies,
on remontait les pierres à la surface.
- C'est à la fois un gain
de temps et d'argent.
Parce que dans un budget de construction,
d'un bâtiment comme celui
des grandes écuries,
la part de l'achat de la pierre mais aussi
de son acheminement est considérable.
Ce n'est pas le seul avantage
dont les bâtisseurs vont bénéficier.
Et notamment lors de la construction
de la pièce maîtresse des écuries.
- Le dôme a des dimensions exceptionnelles
pour un dôme d'écurie.
Il fait 28 mètres de haut à l'intérieur,
sur 20 mètres de large.
- C'est un chef-d'oeuvre
de la taille de Pierre.
Mais les constructeurs français
sont très forts, sont très habiles.
Ils maîtrisent la technologie.
Un savoir-faire indéniable, mais qui
va nécessiter certains ajustements,
en raison de la taille XXL du dôme.
C'est ce que nous explique
Jean-Michel Bouchard,
compagnon tailleur de pierre
et Meilleur ouvrier de France.
- Quand on fait un dôme à 28 mètres
sur une dimension comme ça,
il faut contrecarrer
les poussées de ces pierres.
On met plusieurs tonnes de pierres,
on les claves,
on taille tous les cailloux
à une certaine forme,
pour que les poussées verticales
soient repoussées en horizontale,
qu'elles partent en oblique
et qu'à la fin elles redescendent
dans les murs de chaque côté.
- On a 5 mètres d'épaisseur pour
contrebalancer la poussée de ces voûtes.
- La prouesse architecturale,
en quelque sorte,
c'est qu'on ne s'en rend pas compte,
qu'on a des murs
qui sont plus épais que dans
n'importe quel château médiéval.
Pour s'assurer que le dôme
ne s'écroule pas,
les ouvriers vont également
ajouter un autre matériau.
Le métal.
- Les constructeurs avaient la prudence,
d'introduire des éléments métalliques,
qui pouvaient être à l'assemblage
entre les pierres,
pour renforcer la tenue
mécanique de l'ensemble.
Des prouesses architecturales
d'autant plus exceptionnelles,
qu'elles sont réalisées dans
des conditions de travail épouvantables.
- On sait que le prince de Condé
paye un chirurgien sur place,
pour s'occuper des ouvriers blessés.
On a des témoignages
sur des accidents de chantier,
des échafaudages qui s'effondrent
avec des ouvriers dessus
et donc évidemment,
plusieurs d'entre eux sont blessés.
Mais il y a pire.
Les ouvriers doivent faire face à une autre
menace pour le moins inattendue.
Nicole Garnier est la conservatrice
en chef du domaine de Chantilly.
Lors de travaux de rénovation en 2008,
elle et ses équipes
ont fait une macabre découverte.
- On a trouvé ce crâne humain
qui a été transmis à la gendarmerie,
qui a fait les analyses nécessaires.
Visiblement, il s'agit d'un homicide.
Puisqu'il y a une trace de balle
qui ressort de l'autre côté.
L'analyse au carbone 14
qui a été faite par les gendarmes,
a indiqué que cet homme ou cette femme,
on ignore le sexe,
a été tué entre 1650 et 1950.
D'après certaines archives,
ce crâne pourrait être celui
de l'un des ouvriers,
du chantier des grandes écuries.
Une des hypothèses,
c'est le comte de Charolais,
gestionnaire du domaine de Chantilly,
on sait qu'il a tué certains des ouvriers
qui travaillaient sur ses terres.
- Il utilisait les ouvriers de toiture
pour s'entraîner au tir.
- En tout cas, ça fait partie
des nombreuses légendes de Chantilly
et notamment des légendes
noires de Chantilly.
Ce n'est pas ce possible homicide qui
arrêtera le chantier des grandes écuries.
Mais la mort du commanditaire en 1740.
- Aujourd'hui, les grandes écuries,
on se rend compte,
qu'il y a des parements de pierre
qui attendent une suite.
Il y a un pavillon
qui n'a jamais été construit.
En effet, seule la porte
de ce pavillon a été terminée.
À côté, nous apercevons les pierres
sur lesquelles devaient s'emboîter,
les murs de ce bâtiment.
Les grandes écuries
restent donc inachevées,
mais sont une prouesse
architecturale exceptionnelle.
À la fin du XVIIIᵉ siècle,
le domaine de Chantilly
est au summum de sa splendeur.
- Chantilly n'a jamais été aussi beau
et Chantilly est vraiment réputée,
dans l'Europe entière et va recevoir
des invités venus de toute l'Europe.
Une apogée qui sera de courte durée.
Car tout bascule le 14 juillet 1789.
La Révolution éclate à Paris.
La Bastille est prise,
le pouvoir est renversé.
Dès lors, tout symbole de l'Ancien régime
est détruit par les révolutionnaires.
Chantilly n'est pas épargné.
- Chantilly va être confisqué
et va être vendu à des démolisseurs.
- Le château est peu à peu démonté,
on met en vente tout ce qu'on peut
en terme de matériaux, les plombs des toitures,
les ardoises et toute la pierre.
Une grande partie de la ville
de Chantilly a été construite,
avec les pierres qui viennent
du grand château.
En huit ans, c'est plus de 500 ans
d'histoire qui disparaissent.
Le grand château est rasé
au niveau de ses fondations.
Les jardins de Le Nôtre sont en ruine.
Seul reste le petit château
et les grandes écuries.
- La Révolution française,
c'est le désastre complet.
- C'est le grand vide.
Chantilly se trouve face au plus
grand défi technique de son histoire.
Impossible d'imaginer
que deux siècles plus tard,
le château sera de nouveau debout.
Cet exploit, on le doit
à l'obsession d'un petit garçon.
- Le duc d'Aumale hérite de Chantilly
en 1830 et il a huit ans.
- La renaissance de Chantilly
va se faire avec un enfant de 8 ans,
Henri d'Orléans, Duc d'Aumale,
donc le cinquième fils du roi Louis-Philippe,
le dernier roi des Français.
Après un exil forcé de 30 ans
en Angleterre,
il lance en 1875 un chantier
titanesque de reconstruction.
- Ce château a coûté des millions
de francs de l'époque.
Le duc d'Aumale était l'un des hommes
les plus riches de son temps
et c'était finalement l'œuvre
de sa vie qu'il déployait ici.
Pour réaliser son rêve,
le nouveau propriétaire de Chantilly,
va imposer au bâtisseur un cahier
des charges particulièrement contraignant.
Tout d'abord, pas question de construire
le château ailleurs que sur le rocher.
Alors le duc d'Aumale
avait coutume de dire :
Mes prédécesseurs ont bâti leur château
à cet endroit là depuis 8 siècles
et je ferai de même.
Niveau architecture,
le château doit être réalisé
dans un style renaissance.
- Il va faire des citations,
comme par exemple la porte d'entrée
du château de Chantilly,
qui est une copie de la porte
du baptistère du château de Fontainebleau.
Il va copier la chapelle d'Écouen.
- Ces grandes tours à clocher
du château de Chantilly,
elles vont s'inspirer aussi bien de
Chambord que de Valençay, monuments anciens.
Et pour que l'illusion soit parfaite,
les ouvriers doivent à tout prix dissimuler
les matériaux modernes qu'ils utilisent.
C'est le cas avec l'éclairage de la plus
grande salle du nouveau château,
la galerie des peintures.
Ici 85 des 815 tableaux que possède
le duc de Chantilly sont exposés.
Au plafond, des carreaux de verre striés,
qui cachent une verrière
ultramoderne pour l'époque.
Elle se constitue d'une couverture
vitrée longue d'une dizaine de mètres
et d'une charpente métallique
composée de huit arcs en acier riveté.
- C'est le matériau du XIXᵉ siècle.
- Ça ne coûte pas beaucoup d'argent,
ça va vite, c'est efficace.
Des techniques révolutionnaires
pour le XIXᵉ siècle,
mais totalement anachronique pour
un château d'inspiration du XVIᵉ siècle.
Les ouvriers vont donc rajouter des éléments
de toiture tout autour de la verrière,
pour la rendre invisible
aux yeux du public.
- Ce qui est impressionnant...
Promenez-vous en barque à Chantilly,
promenez-vous dans les parterres,
regardez les toitures,
vous ne verrez pas la moindre verrière.
- Il y a toutes les techniques modernes,
mais bien cachées
pour qu'on n'ait pas l'impression
d'être dans un bâtiment moderne.
Sauf que ce château
est plus jeune que la Tour Eiffel.
Les parterres d'André Le Nôtre
seront également restaurés,
grâce aux avancées technologiques
et techniques de l'époque,
Chantilly renaît de ses cendres
en seulement dix ans.
C'est toujours cette dernière
version de Chantilly,
que des milliers de touristes
visitent chaque année.
Et si rien n'a bougé depuis 120 ans,
c'est que le château est extrêmement
bien protégé,
par le testament du dernier propriétaire.
À sa mort, le duc d'Aumale
lègue l'ensemble du domaine
à l'Institut de France
sous certaines conditions.
- Il demande expressément
qu'il n'y ait aucune modification
dans l'architecture extérieure
et intérieure du château.
Une volonté de protéger
ces lieux d'exception,
qui s'avère être un véritable casse-tête
pour les ouvriers d'aujourd'hui,
notamment lors des travaux
de restauration.
Depuis 2004, 60 millionsd'euros
ont été investis pour rénover le domaine.
À chaque fois, la même difficulté.
Comment réparer sans tout changer ?
C'est le cas ici, sur le toit
des grandes écuries,
où des poutres vieilles de 300 ans
menacent de s'effondrer.
- Les parties altérées
ont été purgées et renforcées.
Et donc ici,
nous avons utilisé une technique,
en conservant la pièce historique
qui est moisé sur ses deux côtés,
d'éléments modernes qui viennent
renforcer la structure.
Et le tout étant cerclé de métal.
- On est obligé de réutiliser
les techniques de l'époque,
les matériaux de l'époque et de respecter
les lieux tout simplement.
Chantilly n'est plus à un défi près.
- Chantilly n'a pas cessé
d'être en chantier
et c'est sans doute aussi la dimension
exceptionnelle du château de Chantilly.
- On a tout ce que l'architecture
et l'art des jardins
a fait de plus beau en France
au cours des siècles.
- C'est le plus extraordinaire
des patrimoines français.
Dix siècles d'histoire
et de construction mouvementée.
1000 ans d'un chantier hors du commun
qui en fait aujourd'hui,
un symbole de l'excellence française
en matière d'architecture.
Le château de Chantilly se voulait
la demeure des princes.
Les constructeurs ont bâti sa légende.